hey das geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video leute ich hoffe
euch geht es gut mir auch juli ist noch
nicht ganz da meine ich das gefühl das
sind im sitz macht den anfang was soll
das denn ich weiß nicht ob ihr dieses
video gesehen haben da haben wir
versucht wirklich betreuung auf versucht
goldene airports zu machen und zwar mit
der methode heilt dip also gewollten
meine airports werben und wir waren die
ersten die auch wirklich gesagt haben
wir förmlich um das case sondern auch
die kopfhörer was dabei herausgekommen
ist kann ich euch noch mal kurz zeigen
dass hier das muster und wir checken
jetzt mal ob es klappt ganz langsam rein
damit die farbe auch gut an helfen kann
da schnell von klein und bereiten
das ist kann das grunzen können wir ja
sehen ja hier haben wir die die sind
jetzt auch komplett trocken ich muss
sagen die kommentare fielen geschrieben
sehen aus als wären die in der
kanalisation gelandet das kann ich
absolut verstehen wobei mittlerweile das
case fühlt sich eigentlich übels leisten
also ich weiß gar nicht was ihr habt
aber das war auch unser erster versuch
wir haben dazugelernt die habe ich aber
insgesamt verlost wenn euch hier sehr
gern meinen in münster nahmen ein volk
über instagram da werden alle sachen die
ich jetzt in videos zu zeigen und danach
nicht mehr brauche verlost oder selber
kreieren was weiß ich und heute machen
wir weiter mit einer idee die wir auch
direkt hatten das gibt es schon auf
youtube also wir sind nicht erstens wir
sind allerdings die ersten die es so
machen wie wir und zwar werden wir heute
passt auf meine playstation 4 ja die
müssen vielleicht ein bisschen
saubermachen
ich war gerade im baumarkt und habe mir
folgende farben geholt ihr konnten auch
beim abstimmen
viele haben sich für neon geld und
neongrün entschieden deswegen hast du
auf dem meer und wurde genau ich erkläre
auch warum weil wenn ich damit jetzt
gleich sprayer und ein bisschen fahrer
soll hier drauf abfärbt man dies gar
nicht
jetzt stellt sich die frage wir müssen
die playstation erster aufmachen also
ich habe mich natürlich im internet
foren oder informiert wie das am besten
geht und man muss wohl einfach nur an
einer seite ziehen
wir haben nämlich nur das obere teil
dass unsere teil ist leider nicht
abnehmbar
ich habe mal gedacht was ist wenn wir
die einfach komplett abgegeben aber ich
glaube das könnte schon nach hinten
losgehen wenn ein bisschen wasser rein
kommt die kanzlei eine tonne treten
so habt ihr schon mal eine playstation
von innen gesehen an die etwas jüngeren
unter euch die von ihren eltern
playstation bekommen haben mach das
bitte nicht nach danke jetzt kommen wir
zu heide methode wir müssen jetzt
erstmal hier diesen großen peltner ich
habe ein größeren gekauft mit wasser
füllen und dann machen wir weiter hasse
und natürlich haben wir auch noch ich
weiß nicht ob das in diesem video schon
machen oder schon schaffen weil wir
wollen es auch jetzt immer richtig
ordentlich machen einen playstation
controller ich habe nämlich noch einen
alten originalen playstation controller
den ich fast nie benutzt habt den fernen
wir auch
[Musik]
alles klar ich habe jetzt gründlichst
gereinigt also hier ist jetzt kein
schmutz wieder rauf oder sonstiges ist
ganz wichtig die unterseite ist egal wie
braucht man nicht und jetzt wollen wir
das ja noch ein bisschen weiß haben
damit diese mehr und habe gleich druck
haftet jetzt gut
[Musik]
ok fertig mit dem weißen jetzt müssen
wir erst mal nach draußen legen zum
trocknen und dann wartet man ein
bisschen weil es ist super super wichtig
wir haben ja frau gemacht wenn es nicht
ganz trocken ist braucht er eigentlich
gar nicht weitermachen
eigentlich könne direkt zu lassen oder
sie doch schon geil aus zwölf sekunden
später die playstation ist gerade
draußen trocknen und wir haben uns
gedacht wir machen hier jetzt schon mal
weiter mit dem playstation controller
ich war gerade extra im baumarkt also
ihr könnt ihr hier sehen wir haben hier
den originalen playstation controller
keine ahnung ab und zu mal mit fieber
gespielt aber jetzt nicht so häufig
verwendet ich war mir am anfang gar
nicht so sicher ob man sowas überhaupt
auch kriegt aber es ist wohl möglich ich
habe gerade im baumarkt so einen kleinen
schraubenzieher gekauft extra für so
ganz neue technik geräte wie laptops
oder halt diesem playstation controller
und das müssen wir jetzt erst mal machen
wir müssen den aufschrauben und dann
natürlich erstmal weiß an strain
ich glaube wenn dann alles fertig ist
und wir haben so ein paar beauty shops
machen hat könnt schon verdammt geil
aussehen oder halt auch nicht
ich schreibe hier erstmal die leute die
schon immer mal ein playstation 4
kontrolle von innen sehen wollten
sowieso raus wir haben jetzt hier den
ganzen ps spielkontrolle
auseinandergenommen und das hier ist
jetzt das teil was wir können jetzt über
diese tasten vertauschen
[Musik]
wohl aber nach draußen muss jetzt
nämlich trocknung leute wir kleben hier
gerade noch so ein bisschen die rinde ab
und haben uns hier noch mit klebeband
angriff gebaut an dem wir das ganze
gleich ins wasser kippen können und juri
macht superarbeit der junge kann ich nun
der kamera halten kann auch heute okay
leute jetzt kommt es darauf an jetzt
entsteht das muster und ich hoffe es
wird geil
wir haben uns jetzt hier den griff
gebaut gehört noch ein bisschen
abgeklebt und jetzt sprechen wir das
wasser an displays einem bloß ne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so laufen oder
[Musik]
alte leute so sieht jetzt die folie aus
ich hoffe es klappt wie ich es muss
klappen 321 langsam ab
[Musik]
beide nicht ganz abschütteln bisschen
der gast auf dem boden glaube ich muss
mal machen geht das neue abkommen das
ist schon geil genug meinte soll ich sag
mal versuchen abzumachen ein paar
sekunden später leute diese videos texte
packen aufwendigsten jetzt kommen der
controller dran und ich hoffe da klappt
noch besser als die playstation am
anfang war die echt nice wir haben
kleine fehler gemacht haben und jetzt
ist es so von hier aus sieht ultra geil
aus film dass er nicht auf zeigen euch
gleich aber wenn man nah dran geht ist
so ein bisschen nach ich weiß noch nicht
deswegen schauen wir jetzt mal raus aus
dem konkordat wird
[Musik]
ja bitte
wer nicht lange gebraucht bestimmt drei
stunden oder so wird also ohne spaß
haben jetzt 13 uhr 23 wir haben um
viertel nach zehn angefangen also gut
drei stunden
es ist eine menge aufwand auch wenn du
jetzt nur das ergebnis seht wir haben
aber auch mehrere anläufe gebraucht und
jetzt hole ich mal kurz die playstation
vita auf jeden fall schon ganz nice aus
also leute 3 2 1 also hier eine stelle
die ist eben ein bisschen viel geworden
aber sonst ist es ganz gut also wenn man
das gesamtpaket betrachtet und jetzt
kommt aber noch krassere dazu ich finde
sehr ist und es noch besser gelungen
der wird auch verlost wie gesagt auf
meinem programm alex w und zwar haben
wir hier den controller die gibt diesen
kontrollen der jetzt noch heftig oder
reicher und legt ihn mal dazu okay leute
ich würde mal sagen wir mal ein paar
jugendschutz oder tierschutz news 3 2 1
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
soviel dazu erstmal wie gesagt er habe
ich noch gar nicht gesagt schreibt auf
jeden fall weitere gegenstände gehen wir
auch noch heiraten sollen in die
kommentare
seid kreativ da machen wir das und
dieser controller wird auf den minister
verlost instagram alex wie jack dass auf
jeden fall ab abonniert den kanal glock
aktivieren morgen meinst man sehen wir
wieder das was mir passt rein
[Musik]